a company approached me and they they
asked us if we could introduce their
latest technology to you it's something
they call a superhero generator a
superhero generator and what is that
it's like a voice-activated 3d printer
that makes actual comic-book superheroes
appear right here on our stage simply by
saying their names
yes sandy that's exactly what it is
gasps yeah it was a really good guess
Wow glad you at rehearsal well the cue
cards were there too all right shut up
there's no cue cards here do you guys
want to generate some superheroes
okay here we go are you ready superhero
generator ready to generate ah okay
generator make Captain America making
patties America
[Music]
people practice American
now now
like it I didn't I didn't say cactus
Americal he didn't
I've been they liked him I think even
more let's try this again but listen
carefully this time make Wonder Woman
making under women
behold under women
this voice recognition software is
terrible I know and try it try it one
more time right okay slowly I guess okay
all right try again
Karen all right all right
last time superhero generator repeat
after me incredible Incredible Hulk huh
yes make the incredible Pope making the
infallible elf
[Applause]
behold the infallible elf
ah look wait a minute that's wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute
that's not even an elk that's a reindeer
you Andy you try finding himself in San
Diego all right
[Applause]
you